you did this thing where you start
typing and you strike me as a type of
person who never texts first and that's
just not gonna work for me
you've always text first it's exhausted
you wake up how early yeah I love
sleeping in way too much for that
I took a glance at your Netflix accounts
unfortunately we do it like any of the
same shows Princess Bride is overrated
oh so you're some kind of a monster I'm
not saying I don't want to date you
because use the wrong you're in a text
but that is definitely what's happening
here
a grammar nazi how charming the amount
of meat you eat makes me more ease
you're going to die before me a vegan I
don't know if I'm ready to be that
open-minded we have a lot of mutual
friends on Facebook this strikes me as a
high-risk situation oh my god your mom
just Facebook friended me way too soon
wow you post a lot of political articles
on Facebook I don't know how I feel
about that the number of hours you spend
on your phone is terrifying
it horrifies me that you don't know what
Instagram is you literally say the work
literally a lot oh you have it selfie
thick how'd it happen you googled me oh
that is so creepy a music snob that's
fine cuz I'll always love Britney Spears
more than you you know this ain't ever
gonna work but we can still make out